So there are lots of different ways to answer this,
especially, depending on your age. Here's one way. So, I'm going to
define the variable, age, and I'm going to use my age in
spirit, which is 7. And then, we'll multiply that by the
number of days in a year. But let's also define
a variable for the number of days in a year. And
we could use 365. If we want to account for leap years,
it would be more accurate to use 365 and a quarter,
since one quarter of the years are leap years.
And to compute the number of days that I've been
alive, we can multiply those two values and print
out the result. So let's try that in the Python
interpreter. So here, we've defined our two variables. We
have age is 7, not my real age, in case
you're wondering. And days_in_year is 365 and a quarter.
So we'll multiply those two to print out the result,
which is 2556 and 3 quarter days. Quest to do
this more accurately, we'd need to use a real age.
And our actual age is probably not an exact number
of years, unless it's your birthday today, in which case,
happy birthday. But otherwise, you'd need to add the number
of days since your birthday to get a more accurate
number. I'll change my age to my real age. And
I will add the number of days since my birthday.
Which is 268, if you're watching this on the day it's
released. And then we got my age, in days, is 14,878. Which
seems pretty old.